hi in this video I'm going to solve
another question from IIT Cham 2016 and
this question is on clipping site on
polypeptide so this question asks that
the following peptide they give a
peptide sequence and was sequentially
cleaved by dithiothreitol cyanogen
bromide and trypsin so in order to
answer this question we need to know
that one at the cleavage site of trypsin
cyanogen bromide and i try out at all
so and then only we can say how many
peptide fragments are produced so let's
see a piece of information so here we
have some agents and their site of
cleavage some popular agents that is hot
favorite varieties one is trypsin so
trypsin always cuts in the c terminal
side of lysine and arginine that means
the basic amino acids so they would
leave after lysine after our gene
whether there is a lysine or arginine
arginine trypsin would cut after it
chymotrypsin another hand would cleave
at the c-terminal end of aromatic amino
acids such as tryptophan tyrosine or
phenylalanine
so these chymotrypsin would cleave the
c-terminal end that means after
tryptophan after tyrosine or after
phenylalanine on other hand side
sandwich and bromide will exclusively
cleave after methionine it would cleave
at the c-terminal end of methionine now
pepsin would cleave at the amino
terminal side of the aromatic amino acid
like tyrosine Trina and ironing and
tryptophan so pepsin and chymotrypsin
their mode of action is almost same but
chymotrypsin cleaves at the C terminal
side of the aromatic amino acid that
means after C terminal after these amino
acid and pepsin would cleave before
these aromatic amino acids so just we
need for this particular question we
need to understand the cleavage site of
trypsin and cyanogen bromide
so for trypsin it's slicing an arginine
whether we see a large
lysine or arginine trypsin would cleave
after that and the cyanogen bromide
would leave after a methionine so let's
see our peptide sequence so here's our
peptide sequence so here is Finneran
tryptophan:lysine lysine is a basic
amino acid so trypsin would leave it
then we see tyrosine methionine after
methionine we would get a cleavage by
sangeun bromide then glycine alanine
cysteine cysteine then prolene then
returning again and there is a pivot
point for a sandwich and bromide
aspartate lysine arginine again arginine
there is a pivotal point for trypsin
phenylalanine
alanine lysine and tryptophan so there
are basic for cleavage site and for
cleavage would produce five fragments
now the thing to be noted that don't get
confused with the function of
dithiothreitol now what is the mode of
action of titrant through tal and what
is the cleavage side of die trial should
all so die trial should all basically
cleave
disulfide linkage so if these are basic
form of a disulfide linkage
dithiothreitol will cleave this bond but
it won't cause fragmentation of the
peptide so here in our structure we have
a disulfide bond between these two
cysteine residues and it would be
cleaved by this die try at all but it
won't produce a more peptide fragment so
how many peptide fragments we are
getting we are getting basically four
peptide fragment let's label them so
this is our first peptide fragment this
would be our second peptide fragment and
this would be our third peptide fragment
or fourth peptide fragment and this
would be our fifth peptide fragment so
the correct answer would be five so this
question came under the numerical
ability section at section and if you do
this question correct you would get
marks and if this question is very easy
and very important for other competitive
exams normative exam asked this type of
question so you just need to understand
these cleavage sites so basically it's
good to remember all these few websites
because question generally comes from
these type of enzymes they you they can
also ask about climate rip scene or pep
scene they can digest the fragment with
chymotrypsin or Pepsi and then say how
many fragments would be produced okay
and this concludes the video please like
and subscribe for more videos hope you
enjoyed it thank you